now lasted well as Deez Nuts operational
force communication whether to issue the
more say you be in shuttle bus shuttle
surcharge epic Rainsy was not on the
Survivor Series here is nice a fact I
was not with this for prescription walk
this issue today at the power of not
sick talkin crap oh well Shasta sweets
Mahalo to ya rihanna's my opinion format
similar words crazy sport one bitch
torsional estas own paparazzi dislike
motivo estas aqui marshal enormous ports
chemical enemies economic media
necessary precipitate a business it's a
li poum investor what if need a little
Tom professor and your cranes in the
Pilate Riccio he carefully associate
professor frosty rocky saluted see
collaboration bata ah super atavistic
all every dish made with the nail the
dishes over yourself kiddo good nike
sports craze different race he teaches
obelisk another pocket the moment upon
the cross and focus on
be here separate even Zanganeh to mobile
in addition to the Toyota mu equal a
sportscaster on da challa British job as
la Rica's alumina proto crazy a post on
ski army subaru of america yes Quezada
vitamin C Tom / MSM on a daily vitamin C
brother documented silico documented
process Alaska weapon is a supernova
stinson the item with a Mercedes initial
Maya was not found original direction
ETA on that Sedna bishop after one use a
problem tomoya domo arigato Moscow
Paratore a demotion 7 division sea cow
from over attitude problem la creme
motherhood is around people sincerely
thank you very much
chance to talk about class
let's make one comment into the kitchen
No
the very careful
a membrane that the jealous
I'm asking about those
Oh
answer what response to my to my cousin
Paige actually to my answer to a
question and that is which retains the
Polish the fiscal that'd be a view that
they're not there the web and still
under the link on how to approach you
gain from involved and also in general
between individual between the members
of a physical sales and that Mecca it's
a question of calculation that number
that the majority certainly follow the
line open for joint second bomb i said i
considered for the baseball
26 and good life hi gerson it's crumbly
however it would be historically
incorrect to say that Bishop have no
political news okay a human being may
happen overnight and some vision as well
not sympathetic to the rock to the 91
good which the fall in which is holiness
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to thank
the panelists not only that are here
present this moment but all day today
promise you that tomorrow we will have
been equally stimulating afternoon
you're all welcome to come it is always
the case that towards the end of the day
you have the most things to say and
people are the most interested in what
happened because you finally have a
chance to think about some of these
issues and that's clearly what happened
during this panel however I want you to
know that people are people that the
line is evaporating in our lobby and
that pollute is going stale so I invite
you please to join us for a reception in
our lobby thank you very much